auf dieser karte sind aktuell mein name
meine adresse mein geburtstag von meinem
versicherungsnummer gespeichert das
klingt erstmal gut endlich weniger
zettel und alles einfach an einem ort
gesammelt kein nerviges hin und her mehr
zwischen den ärzten aber man muss da ein
bisschen genauer hinschauen denn das
sind alles hochsensible daten es gibt
keinen platz auf der welt wo ich die
patientendaten von 80 millionen menschen
sicher verwahren kann
das wiederum klingt jetzt nicht
besonders gut experten und ärzte waren
für einen datenskandal und vor dem ende
des arztgeheimnisses aber unser
gesundheitsminister hat noch einiges vor
und das im besten fall schnell und wenn
man nur bedenken haben aber nie was
möglich machen passiert hat nichts und
wir machen jetzt hier mal was möglich
das gesetz ist beschlossen um 20 21
kommt die elektronische patientenakte
ist das also höchste zeit dass wir mal
darüber sprechen denn es könnte sein
dass vor lauter tempo die sicherheit
vernachlässigt wurde
[Musik]
die digitalisierung kommt im
gesundheitswesen an das ist auch wichtig
und es kann extrem nützlich und sinnvoll
sein keine frage denn dann ist endlich
schluss mit der zettelwirtschaft dem
ständigen ausfüllen von patienten bögen
oder dem herumtragen und faxen von
überweisungen und röntgenbildern dabei
gibt es allerdings auch eine ganze reihe
von bedenken und wir schauen uns jetzt
mal exemplarisch eine sache genauer an
die elektronische patientenakte soll die
medizin versorgung ins 21 jahrhundert
holen darauf kann ich alle daten
speichern die ich will und damit
forschung erleichtern
als grundlage dafür wird im moment die
telematikinfrastruktur aufgebaut das
heißt alle patientendaten sollen zentral
gespeichert und alle teile des
gesundheitssystems vernetzt werden
aufgrund von zeitdruck die der herr
spahn geschaffen hat mit seinem gesetz
und massiven mangel auch an all die
leute sind die menschen in schnell
teilweise online schulungen geschult
worden wir haben herausgefunden dass
teilweise firewalls ausgeschaltet wurden
das sicherheitssysteme deaktiviert
wurden und wichtige schritte nicht
eingehalten wurden
in ganz deutschland gibt es damit
probleme über diese neue infrastruktur
hängen jetzt schon praxen mit den
sensiblen daten am netz und dadurch sind
sie leicht angreifbar jetzt sind ärzte
allerdings keine it spezialisten und in
einem experiment sind wir innerhalb
weniger klicks auf alle daten gekommen
die auf der gesundheitskarte gespeichert
sind und wie eingangs schon gesagt in
zukunft könnte das noch viel mehr sein
als nur ein name
wir haben viele patienten
eine schizophrene patienten depressive
patienten die natürlich absolut nicht
wollen dass diese daten übersichtlich
sind vor allem wenn sie noch berufstätig
sind und das ist ja gar nicht mal so
selten junge menschen die später noch
versicherungen abschließen wollen werden
nicht wünschen dass ihre daten irgendwo
zu sehen sind könnte dann der zahnarzt
von der depression erfahren und der
physiotherapeut vom
schwangerschaftsabbruch mainz bei
jedenfalls sorgt sich um die sicherheit
seiner patientendaten wenn alles zentral
gespeichert wird und wer sich wie er bei
gab deshalb seine praxis anzuschließen
zeit strafgebühren aktuell sind es pro
quartal 1 prozent des honorars und ab
märz 2020 25
das sind jetzt zwei der großen
schwachstellen zum einen die
sicherheitslücken bei der installation
der infrastruktur zum anderen die
vernetzung der sensiblen daten
das ministerium selbst verspricht
sicherheit es teilt uns aber auch
schriftlich mit erkenntnisse über
sicherheitsmängel in der
telematikinfrastruktur selbst liegen
nicht vor
man arbeitet gerade an richtlinien zur
it-sicherheit die systeme selbst sind
allerdings schon installiert und für
kritiker geht aktuell deshalb tempo vor
ordentlicher arbeit werden ignoriert es
wird immer alles kleingeredet wird immer
gesagt so ein einzelfälle der politik
möchte was die politik möchte und das
wird durchgedrückt jens spahn
rechtfertigt das tempo auch mit der
konkurrenz durch internationale konzerne
die lämmer sind die amerikanischen
großkonzernen milliarden chinesische
staatskonzerne übrigens und beide mit
unterschiedlichem hintergrund machen sie
sich mit unserer vorstellung von
datenschutzfragen ich finde solche daten
können einzig und allein wenn überhaupt
in staatliche hände
aber selbst das würde ich sogar ablehnen
eigentlich gehören diese daten notarzt
ausschließlich not zu dem arzt zu dem
ich vertrauen habe dem ich das
anvertrauen was ich gerade dem sagen
möchte und niemand anderen niemandem so
wird es aber nicht bleiben und dass wir
veränderungen brauchen ist klar und dass
sich die digitalisierung nicht aufhalten
lässt auch und zur wahrheit gehört auch
dass wir alle oft sehr arglos mit
unseren daten umgehen fitness apps oder
sonstige gesundheits apps nutzen wir
einfach weil sie kostenlos und nützlich
oder zumindest irgendwie spannend sind
denn sicher sind auch die oft nicht für
die grundlegende infrastruktur aber muss
gelten selbst wenn es 100 prozentige
sicherheit nicht geben kann
ein bisschen mehr sollten wir schon
erwarten vor allen dingen dann wenn man
bedenkt was da alles noch kommen soll
[Musik]